[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right phil we're gonna put 30
seconds on the clock and let's see how
many meals you can raise by making some
putts ready three two one go
that is incredible let's go let's go
that's incredible ten seconds left
eighty thousand meals
feels ready for this
wow that's unbelievable
phil i know you made 15. it's decent not
that good but let's see if i can do a
little bit more
all right you ready
[Music]
oh you need a sword come on i mean was
that
do we even know
[Music]
either anybody know i don't know we'll
roll that back in editing it'll be 16
but bryson you're up
all right everybody phil mickelson made
15 putts in 30 seconds let's see if i
can do better
[Music]
oh who's that
nine
oh i suck
[Music]
30 seconds 10 foot putts which will you
will not hit one i got a grand on it got
a wrap this is golf right this is a
sport it's not even a sport this is a
sport you will not let's prove it right
now you will not hit one putt from ten
feet
[Applause]
[Applause]
okay
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
put a stroke on this man
[Music]
you're joining elite company joining the
match alums what is it like to join this
brotherhood i think it's awesome i look
at the guys that have kind of i guess
come before me uh it's been cool to see
it's been fun to watch and i'm excited
to be a part of it
okay i'm gonna name
fire match participants and you give me
the one word that comes to your mind
when i say okay all right ready yep
still mexican
[Music]
[Music]
um
downtown aaron rodgers
dry humor
awful
awful
[Music]
awful
we're gonna be hitting on top of the
wind oh my goodness why is he smiling
hitting him right in his veneers
do you think it's right on his nose
what's up bleach report bryson d'shambo
here here at the wind about to go up to
one more spot i've heard it's pretty
cool come check it out so we're gonna
head up to uh into the hotel okay and uh
up to the 60th floor
60th we're gonna do something here that
no one has ever done before okay and i
think you're gonna be excited and
interested in the target that you're
about to hit
[Music]
how are you doing
all right headed up to the 64 rooftop
we'll see you up there
bryson come on out here alrighty
this
is kind of insane
i would have never thought i'd ever be
up here in my entire life
[Music]
i'm ripping some bombs off of here oh my
gosh gosh how beautiful is this
oh there he is
why is he smiling
i'm about to hit his face all right
what's the yardage 521 yards wow we're
gonna have you at about 650 feet what's
the slope adjustment down to the target
we have it at 19 degrees with a wind of
about nine and a half miles an hour i
might have that alaska plane right there
okay that's a little little different
than i've ever experienced that is
gone
real short
a little short oh you think
[Music]
all right this is the real deal coming
for you brooks
[Music]
oh it was it hard
this is so much fun
how far short is that
how far short was that one
50 yards to the right right by the water
just just wait guys i'm getting
comfortable still
oh
no just drew a little bit come on ball
that's got a chance
let's get a chance
20 yards short
i see it okay
[Music]
oh it's so good too gosh darn it
oh
it was it hard it's gonna happen don't
worry short and left of the
[Music]
do you think baby do your thing it's
right on his nose it's going right for
him come on
oh
oh my gosh
oh my gosh
two feet short two feet no
no excuses
we're doing it right here right now
shot coming
oh
stay on the target baby
[Applause]
i'ma hit another one
that was sick
[Applause]
let's go
all right i just nailed brooks's big
head on top of the wind 500 yards away
now it's time to go beat his butt in the
real match
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what up everybody welcome to capital one
the match
brought to you by tnt
we are here at the press conference
my name is jake adams i'm here with our
podcast country club adjacent yes sir
sitting here at the end just barely
hanging on to the press conference
that's me i'm mark smalls i fly the ball
no more than 180 yards that's very true
i'm blake weber and brooks kepka stole
my spot at the fsu golf team hi i'm
griff pippen and i eat scones with two
hands
and again i'm jake and i dropped out of
golf college sitting next to me is
because we needed somebody with more
than four majors on the panel
the flop got himself phil mickelson uh
phil you're here to keep these guys in
check
yes a round of applause for phil
uh yeah you're here to keep these guys
in check make sure they don't dodge any
questions
and then of course the stars of the show
bryce and d shambo and brooks kepka
thank you guys for letting us uh take 30
minutes of your life and just overall
make it better you're welcome yep
um before we get to you guys of course
watch the match on tnt presented by
capital one it starts at four pm eastern
if you're watching the pregame press
conference you'll obviously watch the
match i mean who just watches a pregame
press conference yeah i'd be weird
unless you're my mom shout out wendella
love your mom she's beautiful very hot
great beautiful oh okay okay um brooks
and bryson be playing 12 holes today uh
because they ate too much turkey last
night and 18 is a big ask that's a huge
ass for these guys huge especially since
i don't play much golf anyway
competition i don't like it i don't know
yeah i thought that was his job
he played much golf
me and you both
i'm just here to get paid
what do you use on your teeth brooks
they're all fake man oh there's the ears
coming out oh do you have a couple that
you could lend me by the way
he's missing some bullets or something
yeah a couple of them yeah let's not
draw attention to it because it's being
televised on the internet yeah yeah
all right guys so you guys will be
asking the questions that you write in
that we will relay to these guys so drop
some questions in the chat and if we
pick your question
on that spot you just want a hoodie uh
this is that marksman the hoodie he's
rocking down there look at this close-up
look at that dude very handsome you look
you'll look almost as cool as mark yeah
you also got stuff on the sleeves but
i'm 80 pounds that is a large cold up
here that's a large i don't think it
would fit any of these big boys right
here but uh it's a beautiful size that's
right yes sir so why don't we i want to
get into it that's about enough words
out of my mouth currently all right
let's get into our first question this
is from lou 3255 this is for both of you
say something nice about the other
person
uh he's got great teeth oh there we go i
agree i saw him look at his look at his
face right now he's like this is a hard
one very hard i'm still trying to figure
it out
[Laughter]
come on you got to say something though
i am speechless maybe you talk about it
the first time okay with a microphone in
front of my face i am speechless wow
maybe you could still trying to think i
still can't thank the blood is boiling
already if you want to possibly mention
that he has better abs than you that
might be uh oh yeah sure he's got better
he's got better abs than me yeah we'll
go with that good thanks for the
suggestion i know if you saw that pick
that he dropped last night i did my boys
sent that this morning
oh dressy i was just trying to figure
out who oiled them up and took the photo
little oil that was a nice that was a
nice thing of you to say brycey i'm
gonna start calling you brycey there you
go
go for it
also i just want to mention that wasn't
a question whoever uh shout out to
32 55. that was just disappointing
um okay so
uh bryson we've actually met before
and uh we wanted to we want to actually
show you the moment that we met it was a
it was a beautiful moment so if you want
to play that clip guys uh very important
very important to the uh feel like a can
of spam you look like you're afraid to
get off of creatine
did you even use rocket mortgage when
you paid cash for your home
you love to show off your rolex and
bentley we get it your ex hurt you i
heard you got that bentley sponsorship
did rolls-royce pass
come on okay
okay let's go break day
brooks has a way better physique than
you and it doesn't even work out
[Laughter]
thank god they don't
literally i i met bryson and i was
immediately like oh my god we had
immediate chemistry like this guy hits
his drives like he's mad at his
ex-girlfriend he's very insecure and
works out too much and we are both
longer than the average tour pro so i'm
like that's my guy right there i love it
wow you guys are such a cute couple yeah
okay so here is a question coming in
from at e bindle um this one says for
both of you if you only had one club for
an entire round which club would you
make the other guy play with
his driver
he hates it right
with it we got that uh there may be a
new prototype in play so okay okay
um i would probably have him
i'll probably have him hit his uh old
nike clubs
okay oh you got that square that square
sumo yeah
that's old school i don't even think we
were born then by the way bryce i
definitely was i definitely was bryson
are you wearing iron covers on your
teeth
uh yes what's going on though yeah
exactly a little invisalign trying to
straighten them out i'm trying to go the
more natural route compared to
you know the veneer route but more
natural route for the first time
i like that yeah
i'd like to see i'd like to see uh
brooks just play with his driver too and
by the way it's very nice of you to team
up with that nonprofit organization
srixon that was very nice of you
i hope we have some tricks on people
here today
uh mark we got another question uh we do
have another question i gotta make sure
my phone's on low power mode because i
live my life on 13 battery let's go uh
let's go with at no bread no cheese says
if you punch yourself and it hurts are
you strong or are you weak
well
i'd say you're both
i mean phil does it all the time i think
oh wait failure yeah but his face is so
strong
no i don't want to get in the middle of
those two he's such a strong individual
that nothing can break phil there's just
nothing i've tried for years to get into
his head and it just bounces right off
it's impossible maybe take out one of
the 17 chemicals in his coffee
[Laughter]
i'm the only one here who's won a major
this year
also shuts it down also he is the only
one here that beat up geriatrics on the
champions tour as well so
whatever
it's kind of not fair right shout out
phil for a little bit 50 years old on
the hardest golf course in america yeah
that shout out to you
big shout out to you yeah that was that
was impressive
but please get back to those two i want
to hear them go at it go ahead yeah
all right so
strong or weak if you punch yourself and
it hurts what do you think brooks
sure it's wrong i don't know i did what
the hell you punching yourself for
hey man because you you just lost a
major that's why you're punching
yourself yeah who asked that question i
don't know no bread not
oh no that's true i've had a lot of a
lot of losses i mean
not in may
both of you to tiger that guy i can't
believe he's coming back
yeah all right let's uh let's get into
another question here this one's from uh
pat pepperoni that seems like a fake
name for a real person not a real person
yeah um how much do you guys bench
oh i got you want me to go first 275
that's all i got five wow okay that's
lower than that
it's not that it's not that much bench
pressing doesn't create long drives no
it doesn't what creates long drives
speed speed what muscle what yeah what
what should we do
um everything rotational like i do
discus hammer throw i'll throw a
sledgehammer you throw sledgehammer oh
yeah oh yeah i want to see that it's not
just going to be on my youtube page here
in a couple weeks okay do you phil do
you throw sledge hammers to win majors
yes okay with your calves though right
with your cats
only with his cabs
and then brooks what was the question
again how much do you guys got lost in
phil oh sorry do you have a hangover
from taco bell
[Laughter]
look at that turkey broth
i bet you brooks could still get like
old school mexican pizzas from that from
them yeah
that'd be nice yeah wouldn't it yeah
they took it off the menu they took it
off the menu so no shouts out to tacos
so rude yeah what did you have for
breakfast this morning brooks i had a
breakfast burrito oh boy oh yeah
room service is solid man yeah that's
good good spot i'm about to get one
myself uh
3 15. 3 15. 15. wow oh he's got you mark
that's pretty similar i know it's almost
it's almost as much you guys are about
the same it's almost as much as big i
thought the same thing when i walked on
stage yeah not the strongest guy here
yeah exactly he's got you all right guys
before we get to another fan submitted
question we have a video question from
one of the greatest athletes in the game
and when i said athlete i put quotations
in my head uh take it away sir charles
hey bryson uh this is former champ
charles barkley asking you a question
how do you plan on getting in brooks's
head
my favorite technique is just a lot of
trash talk but what is going to be your
technique
i think for me it's going to be when you
know there's a walmart built between our
golf balls then that may get to him a
little bit
being 60 70 yards past him on a couple
drives may help that's kind of my
strategy today
like this i like that
sweet
[Laughter]
cool classic rock
care
it secretly does that was a that was a
four second question that turned into 45
seconds by the way
he would have thought he played football
instead of basketball
they do say that uh basketball is a uh
it's a contact sport but football is a
collision sport so there is you know
there's a lot of things happening yep
there we go all right from our next
question from em falconer who would win
in a boxing wait wait wait what was that
name em
falconer okay yeah i i i did not make
this up what are you trying to what are
you trying to make him lose his career
before it starts
what are you showing him up there
it's a huge moment for us in phil come
on
[Laughter]
i don't think phil's contracted to say
more than seven words this whole press
conference
you have quiet down over there phil yeah
here we go yeah who would win a boxing
match
i have no idea man can we put the gloves
on for the 13th hole would you guys
fight jake paul
for enough money if if would you fight
jake paul if you could win another major
oh oh yeah yeah oh that's a quick yeah
okay
but yeah
okay would you fight jake paul brycey
if if it paid enough yes i would
that's the answer oh that's the game of
golf it's all about money i love it love
that energy
um okay we got another one here from at
katie choi who says uh how many holes
does a straw have
it's a philosophy question yeah what is
that yeah
yeah literally what are these questions
i i asked the fans asked the fans we
didn't write them that person who said
how many holes the straw has just got a
sweatshirt yeah she gets a sweatshirt
dude for that question it's embarrassing
we don't write them we're just being
paid eight dollars an hour to be here so
yeah we didn't write it we're here
relaying what the fans want to know how
many holes
does the straw have
the question was directed at you too
[Laughter]
phil has acted like he's in an
interrogation room
why
does a a manhole why is it circular and
not a square
it's that's easy
yeah
yeah yeah yeah
it doesn't fall in on itself it's the
only geometry that doesn't fall in on
itself oh so why why can you not answer
how many holes a straw has
see this is why we need it for both ways
also it only took 13 minutes for bryson
to mention geometry so that's
real quick
that's all i know
mark you got another question i got a
question this uh this one uh did your
phone still at battery uh we're on seven
percent we switched to low power mode we
turned off bluetooth and wi-fi so we're
doing pretty good let's go here we go uh
me being a chemical guy myself um
this one's coming in from t price seven
eight seven what does creatine taste
like on breakfast cereal
[Music]
wow everybody's a comedian huh yeah yeah
i mean that was a good one i got laughs
from the crowd yeah the crowd used that
too i could answer that
both of you i could answer that one oh
there we go
we have unflavored
vanilla and chocolate they're all
delicious wow nice do you put it in your
coffee
yes okay he was thinking about that he's
like oh no i'm winning majors at 50. i
put more than creatine in my coffee
there's a lot of things in that coffee a
lot of things in that coffee right there
there we go all right so at qbd says
besides golf what sport could you beat
each other in
oh
tennis you guys like tennis well
i give him tennis yeah no chance ping
pong i've played okay ping pong i
watched him play i watched him play ping
pong at the ryder club he's pretty solid
he's good he'll beat me and ping pong
he'd probably beat me in basketball
basketball yeah okay well these
yeah real sports yeah yeah
i think bryson could definitely beat you
on fortnight though he could probably
yeah guaranteed 90s right never played
it so yeah i assume he's probably got
the advantage okay okay okay
that's a good answer who's a better
artist who do you think out of both of
you
okay you just gave that right away i'm
gonna give it to him yeah that's nice
that's not me
okay i did a little drawing back in my
high school years did you okay you're
gonna be drawing some nfts now some
picassos yeah
now nfts you know okay i feel like
brooks could draw some taco bell
i feel like you could if you really put
your mind to it yeah i bet you bryson
could actually draw like a perfect
circle on a chalkboard yeah
well this next question is coming from
one of the most famous golfers of all
time ladies and gentlemen michelle lee
hey brooks would you give up one of your
major wins if i told you you would never
have to play with bryce and dechambeau
ever
again that's a good question
i don't care about playing with them i
like my majors they're pretty good yeah
so yeah
that's a fair that's a good that's i
could care less who i play with
what it doesn't matter
do you feel like if you if you lose to
bryson today you may never want another
major oh huh i'll be all right what if
you think if they got rid of the us open
would you never play golf again
no okay no
he's like absolutely not i'm all right i
will be just fine nothing matters i'm
here to win
yeah i mean i've got a lot of money on
bryson today so i really need you to
show up um but how do you guys feel
who's he thinks like definitely like do
you guys feel like someone's definitely
feeling better yeah do you feel like
there's an advantage yeah
i mean have you seen how i've been
playing lately
yeah i've been playing like pretty bad
i'll be honest okay oh [ __ ] there's two
missed cuts of you know kind of not
giving them the right direction but we
can go further back than that has been
pretty bad so yeah that's true but you
have any injuries
you've had injuries though yeah
i'm not using that as an excuse i'm just
playing bad okay i've just been playing
but again it's 12 holes anything can
happen yeah yeah yeah this is still
holes yeah why did you why did they
choose 12 holes is because it's just you
guys would be too exhausted or what's
the reason for that they wanted to give
bryson a chance to beat his back nine
score at the u.s open
[Laughter]
i'm getting word from the director that
was a little too mean
no no it's good oh i'm totally
comfortable with it okay i recognize
that stuff happens
i mean when you miss cuts too you got to
have some firepower it's just bad luck
bad luck so so bryson when i told you
we're going to play a video for michelle
we were you nervous that maybe you would
show that tick tock that you did with i
know i love
yeah know and she's like you got to do
dude i was like it
it i'm going okay
don't worry oh no what about all your
life choices oh god i'd love to see it
hey man we're trying to get that player
impact money yeah vip baby 20 mil let's
go
oh i hate this i hate that we're about
to have to watch this again oh this is
great
brooks how would you rate my dance moves
[Music]
this is like the worst version of that
pulp fiction dance by the way oh
isn't that cringe that's pretty crazy so
bad i love bryson that he calls it a
point though okay okay
okay you need to know about bryson he
gets it he's trolling all of us he's not
unaware people think he's like this dude
this physics guy with asperger's and he
doesn't understand what's going on
bryson knows what he's doing okay as
long as you called it out dude because
that was i mean i saw that and i was
just like please that was the point yeah
just like brooks acts like he doesn't
care but he does you know anything
yeah
[Laughter]
all right guys well thank you so much
for sending in questions we have about
10 minutes left so you still have time
to drop some questions in the chat we're
gonna
ask one more question we're gonna pick
the best one of the day and if it's your
question you win 500
phil you know the amount that you spend
on breakfast
um but before we get to that i thought
it'd be a nice time to let you guys ask
a question to each other um or if not
maybe phil uh maybe if you've got a
question for these guys yeah phil what
do you got go ahead and read the read
that one off there right what do you got
for us oh no the whole thing was for you
guys to ask your questions
i'm not aware
i'm tapped out phil
i'm just processing what i just saw on
that dance thing
and you know i i've i think a world of
you okay i just think a little bit less
now that's all
that's all i was hoping for
um i mean it was cute it was uh
disappointing though
oh there it is
i love michelle i had to do it for her
she told me i had to do it so i was like
all right whatever it's
it's uh
although it's not you and a thong
okay i remember i remember and and on
your own instagram feed it wasn't a
bathtub though i don't know yeah
i think the world of both of you it's
just
a little bit less that's all wow how
many ballers did you lose with that post
by the way
uh probably a thousand maybe okay that's
not bad that's it's not bad no you're
promoting the youtube now are you
promoting the only fans as well with
that
[Laughter]
now brooks what got you
to do
that particular post
too many make ultras yeah oh yeah nice
you're drinking a lot when you're in the
maldives you're having fun you're
probably drinking a lot in vacation so
that what you do i get like i get like
doing the picture and everything but
then
to press send
and post it that's what i'm wondering
hey man mal thieves
it is funny yeah you know butts are
funny dude hilarious you guys have
different strategies you'll throw out
that video when you're drunk he'll throw
out a crin's video phil will just sit in
a press conference and like i don't care
i won the pga so i like all of your
styles
all right let's get to one more question
before the 500 question uh this one is
from armando trujillo who has the bigger
cavs phil please don't answer
mine are not that big i'll be honest all
right i do have tree trunk legs though
um
yeah they're not great phil i need to
work i need to get on your workout
schedule okay can we can we do a little
something bill can we see can we see
phil can you bless us
oh we can't see a little we can't see
those oh my gosh
through the pants even
massive this got calf cleavage
wow unbelievable okay that's amazing
anyway brooks no
local give it to yeah we'll give it to
bryson okay
okay okay all right bryson that's all
right on the cavs wow
okay all right starts you uh blake do
you want to read the uh the 500 yeah
that's a lot of money man might as well
uh this this question is worth 500 as
you just said from at scott o'donnell 7.
okay this is for both of you guys your
opponent is lining up a putt to win the
match you get to whisper one thing in
their ear to break his concentration
what do you say
that's a good question though that right
this is like the first good question i'm
glad they won the money brooksy seems to
bug him a lot yeah
but yeah
that gets me quite a bit yeah yeah
i mean they had to go to they had to go
to the tour to get them to stop saying
that so i guess yeah bugged him a lot
but
um
what would i say i don't know
well i know what i'd do oh really
insightful stuff oh here we go yeah
really insightful stuff from brooks
there uh no no it's simple i'll just be
walking on
the uh car path with some spikes
your cleats do the talking the spikes
drowned out the sound of his mouth so i
don't mind he's like that's actually
they're fine
would you absolutely find the spikes
don't bug me it actually is way better
i enjoyed hearing the spikes
would you say just not doing a press
conference not during the press card
would you say that was the moment that
sparked the beef
what was the moment yeah what was the
moment
because that seemed like it you know to
us outsiders but what was it
i mean i think that probably just kicked
it all off into
like a higher gear of what it was um
i don't think we've ever gotten along
liked each other whatever
you want to call it but i think that
definitely sent it into
a little overdrive why was there tension
before was that like hey i want to be
the buffest guy on tour no i want to be
the buffett's guy where did that even
start yeah uh
i have no idea i think we played the
masters in 2015 um
you're an am i think right or something
like that we play
yeah or whatever year was but
just
there's not much in common like yeah
just just be flat out honest there's not
much in common there's a lot in common
just two shocked just two alphas
that just don't get along yeah exactly
so would you guys ever write uh diss
tracks against each other to maybe get
some of that player impact money a
little extra p.i.p i could definitely
not be right so i mean i couldn't but
but cringe i could definitely see you
dropping 16.
and phil phil the wise phil do you have
any advice for them and the rest of
their careers ooh do you like how he
threw in wise as his poster
old but he was like you're just like
all seriousness they are
i like and respect both of them very
much they do things very differently and
yet both ways are very successful right
and i i hope today during the match
we're able to ask questions to see a
little bit inside how their mind works
because
they both work so differently yet are
both
so driven to succeed and be the best and
they are they're they're they're two of
the best in the world and
they they can provide some insight and
i'm hoping that this match and the
intimacy that the match has provided on
insight into how a champion thinks will
give the viewer at home
a view of their greatness that you
wouldn't normally see wow wow i'm crazy
that there's there's a round of applause
right there that was the most serious
comment that was made today ever i i
have one more question for you phil who
did you put money on
you can't legally so so
as i as i what i believe is going to
happen i believe that brooks is going to
get off to a one-ups lead in the first
three or four holes i think bryce is
going to win the match two and one
oh
whoa huge phil making a prediction all
right guys well make sure you tune in at
4 p.m eastern this was so much fun guys
thank you guys for being here thank you
everybody thank you y'all thank you phil
for saying stuff at the end there that
was pretty cool um so make sure you
watch the match on tnt a lot of money
has been donated towards charity thank
you capital one for putting this all on
uh these two superstars are gonna battle
it out we have been country club
adjacent follow us on social media yeah
youtube instagram all the all the forums
yep
guys enjoy the match
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
uh
[Music]
you